Speaker 1: We're now learning about the next
phase of obstruction of the House committee
investigating the Jan. six Trump riots, and
it just doesn't stop.
Every week we learn about something like this.
The new one is that John Eastman, that's the
lawyer who wrote the memo explaining how maybe
Mike Pence could overturn the election results.
That guy, John Eastman, is now blocking 30
200 Trump related documents from the House
January 6th Committee, as reported by CNN.
Meanwhile, a Business Insider is reporting
that Eastman is refusing to hand over 37000
pages of emails to the Capitol Riot Committee.
So let's go through what's going on.
John Eastman, a far right lawyer for then-President
Donald Trump who wanted to block his electoral
loss in 2020, is withholding about 3200 documents
from the House Select Committee investigating
the riots.
Eastman previously was ordered by the court
to turn over 101 documents after claiming
some were confidential legal communications
since he's continued to work through 100000
pages of emails from his Chapman University
account that the House Committee wants.
At this time, Eastman is arguing that the
thousands of documents comprising about thirty
seven thirty six thousand pages should stay
confidential.
Federal Judge David Carter may continue to
weigh whether he can keep those pages secret.
Meanwhile, John Eastman is refusing to hand
over 37000 pages of emails to the committee.
He says they're shielded by attorney client
privilege.
A judge is weighing the argument.
Eastman is known for writing a memo detailing
how Trump could overturn the 2020 election.
I think at this point, we should never again
be subjected to a single word about Hillary's
emails.
We should never again be held and brutally
pummeled with the idea that Democrats don't
handle data correctly.
They don't handle information correctly or
any of it.
Now I will be subjected to that.
You will be subjected to that.
We all are going to be subjected to that,
but we really shouldn't have to end.
The strategy at this point is abundantly clear.
They are trying to run the clock out on the
January 6th investigation and they indeed
may succeed.
That's the saddest part.
I have read a bunch of legal opinions about
the strategy and whether it's a moral strategy
or not, whether it is ultimately legal that
they can just refuse to turn stuff over by
the time it's adjudicated.
Republicans may have control of the House
and this investigation will be dunzo, and
there's really not that much that can be done
about it.
That seems to be the strategy because Republicans
have made it very clear if they take control
of the House in November.
And and are sworn into that control in January
of 2023, which is how it works.
This investigation is over.
And I believe they will almost certainly at
least attempt impeachment proceedings of President
Joe Biden.
I don't think they will go anywhere, but I
think that they will attempt it.
They're telling us they're going to attempt
it.
Many of them are, and I believe them.
And this is why they are stalling in this
way.
If they if the circumstances were different
where there were going to be, if there was
a guarantee of not another, what is it, nine
months of democratic control, but rather two
years and nine months as an example?
A lot of these people that are very clearly
just obstructing at this point in time and
spending tons of legal dollars trying to avoid
disclosing information likely wouldn't be
doing it because that timeline two years and
nine months versus just nine months would
almost certainly lead to a bunch of this stuff
being forced to be turned over to the Jan.
six committee because that's what the last
year has shown us.
Much of the many of these challenges to try
to prevent documents from being given turned
over to the Jan. six committee.
Ultimately, a judge says, you got to give
them the information.
We've seen it with Trump.
We've seen it with others.
Ultimately, Kimberly Guilfoyle ends up and
sitting with the committee and whatever else.
But at this point, they have nine months and
really six and a half until the election takes
place.
My instinct is that if indeed Republicans
win in November, that period between November
and January, I don't know how much investigation
is going to take place then.
So in some real sense, if we want to be conservative
about it.
Democrats have like until October to get this
done.
That's now five and a half months away.
The running out the clock strategy does seem
to make sense.
And by the way, this is going to keep happening
until there's actually consequences for it.
Why wouldn't they just dig their heels in
and refused to comply?
Because Trump's entire presidency was What
are you going to do about it?
What are you going to do about it?
Yes.
I said I was going to disassociate from my
businesses and I didn't, and I made 1.6 billion
while I was president and my kids made hundreds
of millions.
And Ivanka was sitting in for my secretary
of state at a meeting, and I can't even give
you the full list of stuff.
And it's been so, so the hell what?
Because there have been no consequences whatsoever.
And I will take it and even step further.
I don't even know how much this committee
ultimately matters.
The committee, of course, if they find evidence
of criminality, they they can and they must
refer it to the Department of Justice.
As of right now, there is no evidence that
the Department of Justice under Merrick Garland
is genuinely willing to bring charges against
any of these people.
I'm not saying Joe Biden should get involved.
He shouldn't.
As I've said many times before, Biden should
have no involvement in saying to the Justice
Department, Investigate here, find charges
here.
Absolutely not.
But put Joe Biden, take Joe Biden out of this
because he's not even involved.
There is no evidence that Merrick Garland
and his Justice Department are really willing
to even consider doing what are admittedly
politically very difficult things when it
comes to the failed former president and his
administration.
So, of course, Republicans are doing what
they're doing.
Why wouldn't they?